it's hard to picture American cities
without the highways running through
their core but highway removal projects
like this one in Boston can give us a
sense of how disruptive it was when the
u.s. built huge highways through the
cities after World War two these new
highways will have a far-reaching
economic impact on the entire nation
that was definitely true
I always revolutionize the way we
transport goods but inside cities they
demolished an isolated entire
neighborhoods they gave wealthy
taxpayers a way out of the city and gave
air pollution and traffic noise away in
and they redesigned urban life around
the car now eighty-five percent of
Americans drive to work every day so why
did American cities agree to build
highways that were bad for cities it's a
really interesting question and part of
it actually goes all the way back to the
1930s when a group of auto interests
such as General Motors triple-a formed
something called the national highway
users company they began lobbying for
taxes that would help fund highway
construction General Motors started to
design what a new highway system could
look like and they displayed that vision
of the 1939 World's Fair with Futurama
an exhibit featuring expressways that
not only connected cities but ran right
through them it was a design that
allowed for more cars and less
congestion by 1955 the Department of
Commerce echo GM's fishermen something
called the yellow book it laid out all
the routes that interstates would take
throughout the country under
Eisenhower's Federal Highway Act of 1956
which funded the national highway system
a lot of it logical it's you know
connecting most of the us's major cities
but the really interesting thing is you
also have highways slicing right through
the down
many of these cities pretty much every
major city in the country New York DC
San Francisco Philadelphia you have
major highways cutting through
neighborhoods requiring the demolition
of lots of housing and other firts
buildings that's largely because some of
the key contributors to the plan were
auto industry members but no urban
planners and that's because the
profession barely even existed at the
time nowadays there's a value placed on
preserving neighborhoods on keeping
cities intact and that concept just
really didn't even exist in the 40s and
50s when people were talking about
connecting the country with highways it
seemed pretty natural just to drive
highways through the center of cities as
well local municipalities were
particularly eager to build highways
under this plan because 90% of funding
came from the federal government and the
other 10% from States there's also a
darker side to the reason why all these
planners wanted to build highways
through downtown's and urban
neighborhoods highways not only paved
the way for more and more white people
to move into homogeneous suburbs they
also provided cover for targeted
demolitions inside the city during that
era federal policies and implicit
priorities of planners dictated that you
have you know vibrant dense downtown
neighborhoods filled mostly with
african-american residents instead of
being preserved under the plan they were
slated as targets for removal they were
considered light and an easy way of
getting rid of that blight was by
demolishing them and paving a highway
through it neighborhoods and streetcars
were pushed aside to make way for the
automobile look at the neighborhoods of
Black Bottom and Paradise Valley in
Detroit when you go back to the 30s and
40s these are thriving dense
neighborhoods filled with hundreds of
thousands of residents of businesses and
if you go back today they're mostly just
empty grass plots this wasn't just a
historical accident it became a pattern
in cities across the country poor and
minority residents were displaced to
make way for highways and white
residents use those highways to commute
into the city for jobs and commute back
home at night
the only exception to this pattern is in
places where highways were slated to go
through wealthy neighborhoods they were
actually proposals to put a highway
through Northwest DC and through
Greenwich Village in Manhattan but you
can guess what happened there anywhere
where residents had the means to
organize and protest they were often
able to stop the highways from being
built
whereas in places where residents didn't
have the political capital and other
sorts of privileges that allow you to do
that their neighborhoods ended up being
demolished and they're now highways
today even before he signed the Federal
Highway Act of 1956 Eisenhower was
already a really big fan of highways in
general part of that has to do with his
time in Germany during World War two
where he realized how important it is to
have a good system of highways to
transport goods and people very
efficiently but also has to do with this
military road trip that he took in 1919
where he went all the way from
Washington DC to San Francisco
California and that road trip took 62
days at the time and today it takes
about 42 hours and part of that had to
do with the state of cars at the time
but also had to do with the state of
roads at the time and after seeing that
he realized that 62 days was way too
long to wait in any situation where they
might need to defend the country and
that's where he became such a big fan of
highways